nuestro bueno se ha convertido en un
ritual estos socorristas se reúnen y
rezan antes de entrar en las zonas de
riesgo que conducen al isi saints
algunos de los voluntarios de las
organizaciones de ayuda no son
religiosos pero la parada en el camino
como un momento de reflexión se ha
vuelto importante para ellos ya sea
porque la parada para rezar les impidió
estar bajo un proyectil ruso que cayó
justo delante de su furgoneta blindada
pero también durante los últimos dos
meses ya que el equipo arriesga su vida
para evacuar a los ucranianos atrapados
algo acaba de aterrizar muy cerca así
que vamos a ir a comprobar cuál es la
situación pero ha estado aterrizando
todo el día muy cerca de la policía así
que toda esa zona es muy peligrosa katia
es una de las civiles a las que el grupo
ha venido a ayudar con apenas unos
minutos para hacer la maleta solo se
llevan los documentos importantes ella y
su familia decidieron que era el momento
de huir del isi sans después de que un
proyectil ruso impactará en su jardín y
de que su marido viera a su vecino
decapitado por los bombardeos mientras
hacía cola para conseguir la poca agua
que queda en la ciudad y no para ni mal
nos damos cuenta de que aquí no habrá un
final feliz ya habíamos perdido toda
esperanza de salvarnos
yendo de casa en casa llamando a las
puertas la siguiente parada la vivienda
de saia que se cree que ha sufrido un
derrame cerebral lleva cinco días sin
recibir atención médica y ahora ya no
puede hablar
no te asustes todo va a estar bien
mientras las familias petrificadas
siguen siendo de los titanes las
autoridades creen que quedan hasta 8000
personas
fue muchas de ellas demasiado asustadas
o incapaces de emprender el peligroso
viaje fuera de la asediada ciudad